وقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انطلاقه
تدريبات لقوه اسطول الشمال في الجيش
الروسي وقد اوضحت الوزاره ان التدريبات هي
جزء من التمارين السنويه لقوات الاسطول
يشارك فيها اكثر من ثمانيه الاف جندي
وعشرين سفينه حربيه وهوصات وسفن دعم وبحسب
الوزاره تشمل هذه التدريبات تنفيذه عمليات
خاصه لعزل مناطق العمليات وتطبيقات وتدمير
مجموعه تقريبا واستطلاع وقالت الوزاره انه
سيتم النشر جزء من القوات الساحليه لحمايه
اتصالاتها الطريق البحري الشمالي اضافه
الى المواقع المهمه والدفاع عنها
في غضون ذلك تفقد وزير الدفاع سيرجي شايغو
تفقد حاميه نائيه للاسطول الشمالي في
القطب الشمالي وقد نشرت الوزاره فيديو
قالت انه للجوله التي قام بها الوزير
الروسي مشيره الى انه اطلع خلالها على سير
المهام الوحدات المتمركزه في ارخبيل
نوفايا زميليا والمهامه الموكله اليها بما
في ذلك استعدادها لحمايه المنشات ذات
الاهميه الخاصه والدفاع عنها